venture capital is something you hear
about all the time in tech but do you
know what it is or how it works could
you explain it to people at a party well
if not we got you venture capital is
money that is provided by investors to
startups that have the potential to
reshape markets and grow very fast the
money deployed by a VC firm usually
comes from institutional investors
corporations or wealthy individuals
looking to make some serious dough let's
say Jayne and Brian have a camera app
that's getting a lot of customers and
media attention they know their little
company could be ballin one day but the
banks are hesitant to lend the money
because they think it's too risky
but Marcus a successful VC looks at what
Jayne and Brian have done and thinks the
benefits outweigh the risks he gets to
know the to learns about their product
reads the business plan and finds out
how much they've done so far Marcus
likes what he sees and decides to invest
in Jayne and Brian's company he does the
same in varying amounts to other
startups with similar potential because
in the VC game you need a back-up plan
about three out of every four startups
fail so VC has to make sure the projects
that do make money make enough of it to
cover the losses of the failures they
also have to make sure that the parties
who back them get a healthy return on
their investment even with the risks VCS
love tech startups because of their
ability to scale easily as for how much
money Jayne and Brian would get that
depends on where their company is at
seed funding is at the earliest stage
basically something to get the party
going Series A is for when the company
has established product and market fit
started to make some serious buzz and
its customer base is growing fast
Series B is when the company has started
to make some considerable revenue in
select markets and is looking to expand
operations Series C and onwards is when
the company has grown up and is likely
operating on a global scale it may be
ready for an IPO to be bought out by
another company or continue operating as
a private firm so let's say Jayne and
Brian have stayed in the game gone
through Series C and are now ready for
the next step they decide to IPO making
their company public on the stock market
that goes well and Marcus sees a nice
return on his initial investment so
there you have it
venture capital is a high-risk
high-reward game that funds innovative
ideas and keeps the tech world going